foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studio it's the Ramsay show where that
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Christina Allen's number
one best-selling author and Ramsay
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions about your life and
your money the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in and we will talk Christina
big announcement today it's been a week
of big announcements by the way good
announcements we've launched the gazelle
debit card on Monday and today we are
announcing the coolest thing I've done
and I don't know when so for those of
you that don't know we have a campus
here south of Nashville and Franklin
Tennessee beautiful Franklin Tennessee
with a
a couple of uh you know about 400 000
square foot of office space that'll hold
up to two thousand people we've got
about a 1100 in it including our lobby
and our broadcast Studios which are on
the lobby and we've usually got 50 to
200 people out here watching the show
every day when we're doing it uh we
don't charge for that because it's
pretty much like watching ugly paint dry
but um we're glad you're here studio
audience thanks for hanging out with us
and uh up on top of the hill on this
campus we started construction of a uh
the Ramsey Event Center uh it will be
completed at the first of the year and
holds about 2500 people and so we've
been trying to figure out
what our launch event is in this massive
50 million dollar event center that is
absolutely lights out fancy cool fun and
we're excited about it so what we
decided to do was to do a smart
conference but a special kind of smart
conference for a Nashville experience
smart conference traditionally has
started early on Saturday morning and
gone all freaking day on Saturday and we
touch on every area of your life we just
did one in Dallas the other day we talk
about career and money and Christina was
there Jade warshaw our newest Ramsay
personality was there of course Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney George Campbell
Rachel Cruz me we had Craig and Amy
groshel in from Life Church to speak on
marriage we talk about money and
marriage and mental health and career
and every area of your life all day long
that's a smart conference we've been
doing those for about five or six years
and with various different speakers over
the years so this is a new thing we're
going to start on Friday night and go
all day Saturday as well as some special
Nashville
well we're in Nashville it's got to be
some special Nashville guests don't you
think Christina of course and um
since I don't know who they are yet we
can't tell you who they are yet but uh
I'm probably going to call in a couple
of favors with some of my buddies that
are in the the business here and it'd be
pretty cool to get it'd be cool if we
could get some cool people to show up
and in addition to the cool people that
work at Ramsey but uh so it's going to
be a Nashville experience the issue is
this the smart conference in Dallas was
6 000 tickets sold it's typically a six
two and eight thousand ticket event the
conference center the new event center
only holds 2 400 people
so that's a problem for you people
because this thing is going to sell out
in a freaking heartbeat especially VIP
seats and platinum seats and they go on
sale right now Ready set go at this
instant you can go for the first time
ever to ramseysolutions.com events and
get your tickets right this second the
dates are April 14th and 15th it's a
Nashville
experience Friday night and Saturday and
so what you're going to do because
Nashville's a Cool vibe I mean you're
going to come come in on Friday morning
you're going to go to the event on
Friday night and Saturday Saturday night
you'll have off in Nashville and you get
to stay over the weekend and you get to
make a Nashville thing out of it and
you'll plan the rest of your trip but
we're going to give you an anchor Point
here with the smart conference as the
inaugural event at the Ramsey Events
Center
you'll get commemorative tickets
so when the Nashville Predators came and
opened up uh whatever it was 15 years
ago 12 years ago or whatever my son
Daniel and I went to the very first game
whoa and they gave out you know
commemorative pucks and tickets that
were you know Fancy Fancy Fancy tickets
I've still got those
on you know stored away as a memorabilia
at the Ramsey household just because I
was there the day that it started well
that's kind of what this is you're going
to be there the day that the new aramsey
events center starts and oh by the way
while you're here all weekend we're
going to give you the information change
your life and you'll be smarter
that is awesome this event we just did
last weekend was so cool and I can't
wait to bring it to our own Center yeah
it was my first Ramsay live event and
man the energy was just electric the
feedback we've gotten the team just
coming back everybody is just kind of
bouncing off the walls so excited about
how it went yes so we launched the brand
new gazelle debit card on Monday we're
launching Live Events left and right the
Building Wealth events the new dates for
the spring and today April 14th and 15th
with commemorative tickets surprise
guests
um a different format of Friday night
and all day Saturday smart conference
and a very limited seating because
traditionally these are six to eight
thousand and we've only got 2400 seats
up there so we're going to sell 2400
commemorative tickets and you'll have
your Nashville experience lined out for
the spring it's a cool thing so get get
your tickets while you can
ramseysolutions.com events smart
conference on sale right now Ready set
go I love it yes I'm personally excited
about these surprise guests we have so
many people that are amazing right in
our backyard I'm I'm eager to see who
you're going to bring in no they just
show up around here occasionally and pop
in and pop out and uh those of you don't
know the Ramsay Show starting as the
money game and later the Dave Ramsey
show has been on the air here in
Nashville for 30 years and so I've
gotten to know most of the music
Community through the process and uh
um you know they pretty much fall into
one of two buckets very very very
business savvy and good with money or
completely freaking clueless with money
one of the two they thought so I've
gotten to meet with them in both cases
and uh you know have dinner with them
and help them out in either case and
when they did stupid with zeros on the
end or when they were doing something
really smart and just asking my opinion
and um and I've gotten the pleasure of
getting to know them there's a lot of
good folks in the music community in
Nashville so we'll see if any of them
show up no promises because I don't have
them booked and I can't go to air which
stuff I don't have booked so we'll just
kind of tease it out there that it's
going to be a special Nashville event
and you don't want to miss it April 14th
and 15th oh that's like tax day that's
perfect huh yeah quite the celebration
we ought to celebrate that and we'll
probably have some Firearms involved no
I'm kidding oh my gosh all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we invite you to jump
in and we'll talk about your life and
your money it's what we're doing here
again the gazelle card the debit card
from Ramsey is now available uh and it
allows you to spend and save the Ramsay
way at ramsesolutions.com
we've had tens of thousands of you
already open an account already download
the app and we've got your gazelle cards
being printed and shipped to you very
soon and no fees
hooks seamlessly with every dollar you
don't want to miss out on that so lots
of fun stuff happening around here this
week it's a good week to be at work here
funny funny funny good stuff open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality is my co-host today Jake is
with us Jake's in Chicago hi Jake
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thanks for having me thanks for
taking my call sure awesome so my
brother and sister have been married for
a number of years and they've been
trying uh very hard to start a family
um they have been unsuccessful and
they're now attempting uh IVF
um and I've been the Most Blessed out of
all of us kids uh financially and I want
to
help them with that financially and call
in to figure out what is the best way to
do that from a tax perspective last year
I itemized my taxes so I'd like to have
that nice chunk as a write-off but I
also don't want them to I just want them
to have the maximum amount of that sum
yeah it won't be a write-off for you
because they're not a non-profit
okay but you can keep them from being
taxed on it or you from getting a gift
tax on it a couple of ways
um what is your total net worth
over 300 okay over 300 000. how much
money are you talking about giving them
ten thousand up to ten okay it's very
easy an individual can give another
individual up to 16 000 in this calendar
year
in 22 without having any gift tax or any
problems so if you just write them a
check for 10 grand it's perfectly okay
it's not deductible there won't be any
gift tax on it and they won't have any
income tax on it
okay
but you're not but it's not deductible
how would I go about doing a deductible
if I wanted to do that like they have a
GoFundMe right now
um but I know that take a that's going
to go from these aren't deductible
they're not no absolutely not not unless
they're associated with us 501c3
yeah you've got to have a 501c3 and you
can't run something good through
GoFundMe and just determine you know I'm
raising money for my Chihuahuas Nail
clipping on GoFundMe and all the other
crap that's on there and um you know and
suddenly it becomes a tax deductible
Ministry it's just not
um the only way I could think you could
do it
is if
um you gave it to your church and they
gave it to her
but that that could fall under directed
giving and it could cause the church a
problem in the event of an audit
honestly
if I'm in your shoes I wouldn't screw
with it I would just give them the money
and not worry about the taxes
okay I think you're going to get your
there's too many bloops to jump through
too many potential pitfalls with you
trying to create a deduction for doing
it and just not worry about it what if
they had some sort of non-profit that
they went through for fundraising for
example I know like live song for
Orphans we've given to a family who was
trying to adopt a child and they'd
partnered with them it was kind of like
a GoFundMe for that and that was a 501c3
yeah but that's not a GoFundMe that's a
it's a 501 C3 that's supporting this
family and you can give money to them
and so you can give money the Red Cross
and they give it to a family that's
deductible okay but you can't just
GoFundMe is not GoFundMe is not no but
the uh but you have to be careful
there's a thing the IRS calls directed
giving where you're trying to create a
tax deduction where there really
shouldn't be one and you're running it
through something like that they'll step
on that pretty hard they're really tough
on churches on it and so um you can do
it but you have to be just very careful
and there's a lot of little fine print
and for the deduction on 10 grand it's
just not worth it it's not worth it it's
not gonna save you that much and I I
would just help them you've got the
money uh just right if it was us now
if you want to get super fancy you know
like the Ramsey Family Foundation
we can give to individuals like we help
single moms in situations we'll buy
somebody a car or we'll do something
like that in different situations or we
could do help somebody with an adoption
something like that but the foundation
is set up as a 501c3 and it's Charter
the way it's put together with the you
know the paperwork with the IRS allows
us to do individual to minister to
individuals as well as also give to
Ministries and so um in our case but
that's a super expensive thing to I mean
we put a lot of money through the
foundation every year and it's all tax
deductible but uh and some of it goes to
individuals in situations like that and
it's perfectly legal that way but that's
not for 10 grand it's just not worth the
trouble it might cost you fifteen
thousand dollars to set up a foundation
like that in legal fees so it's just not
not worth fooling with you know it is
funny it is you know it's expanded just
a little bit we need to say 16 000 an
individual can give an individual so if
it's
a married couple giving another married
couple for instance mom and dad passing
some money to their kid okay a married
couple to buy a house maybe or something
like that you can give 16 000 individual
to individual so you can pass four times
that mom gives son 16 and
daughter-in-law 16 Dad gives son 16 and
daughter-in-law 16. okay and so now
we've got what is that sixty four
thousand right four times Sixteen Going
you can move without but you have to
write four checks be very specific that
this is from her to her from her to him
and so on and so that if you get audited
then you don't get into a a gift tax
situation so you can move that much
without any taxes as well if you're just
trying to avoid gift tax all right up
next is going to be Jessica in
Louisville Kentucky hi Jessica welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi oh my gosh thank you so much for
taking my call I am the biggest fan and
I listen to you every single day and my
three teenage boys
um listen to you in the car and so
they're really learning some great stuff
too
um but just to keep it brief my question
is my husband and I are on baby step six
um we are down to the last 25 000 that
we owe on the mortgage and we have been
hitting it hard like the last four
months gazelle intense and cut out all
spending only buying groceries gas just
the necessities and so my question is
originally we were going to pay it off
May of 23rd June of 2023 we've moved it
up to March of 2023 and now that the end
of getting to the point where it's in
sight
um my son the other night asked if he
could come if we could take him to
Nashville at the end of December for the
Titans Cowboys game and I said the only
way I'm going to Nashville is if I can
go see Dave and do our debt free screen
on the stage so I want to know would it
be okay for us to take the remaining
money out of our emergency fund
to pay off the mortgage or should we
just be patient and pay it off March 1st
like we were planning
well it's not an emergency
no okay no we don't we generally use an
emergency fund for emergencies right
absolutely okay how much is in your
emergency fund
so right now we have 37 000 in the
emergency fund and then like just six
thousand and like a sinking fund for
cars so that 37 000 and if we did pay
off the mortgage our monthly
um expenses would be right at three
thousand dollars so if we took that down
to like 17 or 20 000 we would still have
that six months and that emergency fund
to cut you know to cover an expense well
if you've got six months in your
emergency fund When the Smoke Clears on
this question then you've got an
emergency fund that's over funded
right it is and with our mortgage it's
it's close to being right it's still a
little bit over but like if we take this
um we're north of 200 000 probably 250
with my side hustle I would use the car
money in a heartbeat
okay okay we'll just delay buying a car
we'll get the house paid off because
you're really focused on the house
payoff I'm willing to do that
um and I'm willing to bring the
emergency fund down as long as it's not
dangerous I just don't want to invite
Murphy because when you don't have an
emergency fund you're sending an
engraved invitation to crap to come
visit you
oh and he's shown up ever since we got
really aggressive like we had a 2700 car
repair and we had an unexpected water so
yeah so if you have three of those and
and then you end up making 200 000 a
year with a paid for house and you're
broke and can't eat I don't like that
plan
okay so you gotta you gotta stay above
that right but if you're sitting there
with 20K
and you can still make it and you use
the car money does that sound okay to
you yeah absolutely my first thought is
yeah what if your roof leaks what if you
know the car breaks down on the way to
Nashville there's so many things that
could happen so yeah you just you just
don't want to go down too close you
don't want to violate where you're below
the three to six months of expenses
guideline because you're just asking for
crap you know and if you can do it and
not get below that then yeah and I'm
definitely using the car money that's a
no-brainer but I think you're gonna make
it I got a feeling I got a feeling
you're focusing well you've got such a
great income it's like I think if you
all pretty aggressive between now and
then you got a good shot yeah and by the
way we don't recommend it's not our
program to be that intense when you're
at baby step six but it's okay if you
want to be this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Greg
and Becky here with us hey guys how are
you hi all right I'm great good welcome
good to have you where do you live
we live in McKinney Texas oh we were
just there oh yes we saw you on Saturday
okay we were there we were there too
heading over the airport drove right
through McKinney yeah right afterwards
yeah very cool good to have you guys all
right how much debt you paid off
well this last stretch was 77 470. okay
how long did that take seven months all
right and your range of income during
that time well going back all the way
when we started this journey with about
65 000 now it's about 180. okay so you
you sound like you've had a it's a 13
years a given a take so give us the
story what happened here well uh back in
2010 when we all started this debt-free
journey it was started because of
foreclosure and uh in California just
broke and hopeless and lost the condo
eaten Ramen and noodles and oatmeal
three times a day so she'd have food and
Jackson have food
and that's when we found you wow through
some friends of ours so
it took us about two years to pay off
that initial fifty eight thousand
dollars of Consumer Debt and then we
ended up moving to out of California to
Texas we fled call me fornia yes
I had to get it in there so
um spoken like McKinney yes I like it we
ended up settling McKinney we bought a
house in 2013 and as we started staring
down the figures and we broke that six
figure Mark we're like okay how do we
get this done now yeah and that was in
January and then in July we sold it or
sorry we paid it off we paid it all
sorry so this is house and everything
house and everything so this story goes
from foreclosure to paid for house yes
sir yes in 13 years wow nice story arc
well done y'all thank you thank you very
cool if we are from desperation to
completely peaceful and satisfied oh
yeah it's all her
she's the one been driving this train
and doing a lot of the lifting and I've
been on it as well but I mean it doesn't
happen without her she's kept track of
all the money and and made sure
everything gets done the way it's
supposed to and it's it's her well this
is the man that will sacrifice for our
family though we drove hoopties I'm sure
the horrible car about the same color as
your car will pop up here there it is I
hate that car the
um yeah the AC went out in Texas
um and he's he drove it he drove it to
work and back
um our parents gave us cars at different
times to help us get through because we
didn't have the money and we were saving
and we were working so hard so this is a
man that will do whatever it takes to
get it done so it's the the patience and
the perseverance and all the planning
it's really
13 years is a long time but I wouldn't
change it amen that's amazing y'all have
really committed to this journey you
also had a big income jump what was that
so 10 years ago when we were in McKinney
um a lady sitting across the table from
me she's here today supporting us she
moved away to Texas and she said would
you like to be a hairdresser and I was a
hairdresser in California but she asked
if I would take over her business that
was a huge blessing having her move away
but that has basically doubled our
income so I went back to work basically
okay but it was and I got a couple of
promotions here and there and moving up
and what do you do I work for Toyota
okay doing what I work for I'm basically
a liaison between Toyota financial and a
handful of dealerships in Texas and
Oklahoma so very cool driving that
hoopty working at Toyota
sacrificed you up your income of all the
things you did what would you tell
people is the key to getting out of debt
I would say just be persistent be
patient I mean there were times where
you just look at all the debt and go how
are we going to do this but you know you
find ways to get it done whether it's
you know changing your shopping habits
whether it's giving plasma or driving
Uber or you know driving things that you
don't really want to drive knowing
that's just for a time just remembering
it's just for a time I think I had
that Dave Ramsey voice in my ear a lot
saying that just for a time is just for
a time and um so just keeping your eye
on the goal the end goal was to change
things for us but change things for them
too yeah we wanted to give them a better
opportunity and show them a different
way so it was more about more than just
us that we're thinking about yeah live
like no one else and show later you can
live and give like no one and based on
that car we lived like no one else I had
children making fun of my vehicle
sometimes like Hey listen if you haven't
driven a car people made fun of you and
lived yeah life is good you need a car
you need a car at one point in your life
that's so bad it needs a name yeah I had
old blue old blue was a piece of crap
yeah yeah you got to have one of those
and so you can tell the grandkids back
in the day we drove you gotta you gotta
have something to tell them right yeah
walk uphill both ways in the snow yeah
and it's just yeah you got to be able to
do that so well done you guys thank you
well done how's it feel to be free house
and everything feels great yeah when we
got back from the bank you know and we
paid our final check I remember coming
back to the house thinking I own that
weed and I own that pool and I own
everything about this house it's all
mine and everything else is just pure
profit from here on out it's just it's
just gonna go up you know we're finally
out of the pit and y'all said on
Saturday we're standing at the top of
this pile of mistakes that we've made
and we put our flag on the top and we
said no more and we're done and we did
it yeah
um so I'm just oh just feels so good
yeah well you know the funny thing about
paying off the house too we walked into
the bank to actually make that final
payment they didn't know how to process
it yeah I think we were there like 40
minutes we're like we'll wait you just
take your time you're going to figure it
out
not today boys and girls yeah I love it
well well done you guys very very well
done so what's next now that now that
you have no house payment no what's your
first big buy first big expenditure well
a car well well no we we sold my truck
this year to get that last 77 000
knocked out so so he sold his Tundra
somewhere we'll get another car I'll get
another truck somewhere you know to be
in Texas and have your Tundra it's kind
of like yeah you can feel the pain
you know I didn't want him to sell it I
was like no you never have anything nice
this is your nice truck it's paid for
why would we get rid of it but he said
Becky so that we can all have more
freedom we'll get another truck down the
road it doesn't matter there's always
another vehicle until you have your home
paid off you can't explain to other
people how it feels yeah it doesn't
matter it's just because you know all
that research we did says that 100 of
the foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage you know and you don't have one
and there's just something that snaps
when you don't have that and the piece
floods in so well done y'all very very
well done hey we got a copy of Total
Money Makeover for you to give away to
somebody you know somebody's on the
journey you can't help but talk about
this stuff because it's changed your
life and uh the baby steps millionaire
book uh which is your next chapter in
your story you're on your way to being
that what's the house worth
well there's some debate there's
probably around 490 to 500. how much is
in retirement
um about another
435 so you're right on the cusp of being
baby step millionaires
so really from foreclosure to
millionaire not just paid for a house
but to millionaire in 13 years yes yeah
from the very very bottom the worst of
the worst to where you stand you guys
are rock stars absolutely amazing couple
we appreciate your help thank you very
very well done also got a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
again use it or give it away and re-gift
it to someone that's what the purpose of
the live and give bundle is for for you
to enjoy it and to give it to other
folks all right bring the guys up let's
introduce them and give them their ages
because they've been on this journey as
well this is Austin he's 11 and this is
Jackson he's 15. all right well they
look like they've been fed pretty good
they're okay I think they're doing all
right yeah they're not too they're not
too skinny no life's pretty good and
they're sitting in a dadgum millionaire
household that's pretty cool do you ever
think that
that's pretty cool very neat very well
done all right Greg and Becky Jackson
and Austin McKinney Texas baby steps
millionaires are almost with 77 000
house now
last seven months the whole journey 65
to 180 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one we'll get
free
[Applause]
done
that's a true definition of a baby
stuff's millionaire that's what happens
when you go through financial peace you
work the plan you do the stuff this is
how it works boys and girls this is how
it works this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jack is with us Jack is in Des
Moines Iowa hi Jack welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Hi how are you
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
so I got a little bit of an emergency
going on
um I just got told that my furnace is um
unrepairable it can be repaired but the
cost of it would be as much as a new one
and I was and I'm on baby step two I got
my thousand dollar emergency fund and I
I just wanted to get a little bit of uh
advice on how how to approach this is it
okay to borrow for the difference to buy
a new furnace because Windows around the
corner and I I I just I I just know I
should ask you because you'll tell me
what to do I'll definitely tell you what
to do I'm always good at that I'll also
tell you what not to do so uh yeah how
old are you
23 and are you married
no okay
um how old is the house
um a 80ish how old is the furnace
31 years
okay
okay well the heating and air business
um has two types of people in it
uh honest and dishonest
and one of the techniques that is often
used in the heating and air business is
they come out to inspect your repair
with the sole goal of replacing your
furnace
and I don't know which one you've gotten
hold of here it sounds like your furnace
is ancient
and I also know that the price range of
getting things fixed and or replaced
will vary dramatically depending on who
you talk to in the business okay you're
23 years old and you're broke you need
you do not need to make a furnace
investment here you just simply need
heat
so the cheapest methodology for you to
have heat this winter is what I'm after
okay so what that tells me is you need
to talk to two or three more heating and
air people and what I would love for you
to find is a small time heating and air
person that some of your parents friends
know or something like that that has
maybe one truck and uh maybe he's going
to come over because he's not going to
be retail and he's going to help you
figure out a way to oh put a little a
little duct tape on this and get the
thing going right because that's really
what we're trying to do all right we're
trying to not put five thousand bucks
that you don't have into this
exactly yeah no I I know exactly I know
what's wrong with it um the control
board was bad on it um but he he got a
new one put in but then he started
testing the other stuff and it still
wasn't firing well he is assuming that
because there's no the pressure switch
isn't activating that the exchanger is
clogged and it's behind everything he
told me it was just gonna be labor
intensive and and to get it unclogged
you have to unhook everything and then
he said so what's the quote now what's
the quote
uh uh about four thousand to fix it
yeah to fix it because that's a lot of
Labor to unclog an extension
exchanger exchanger I'm gonna rest my
case here I'm gonna say you need to get
a somebody else look at this and get
another opinion or two or three because
the option you have on the table sucks
even if it's accurate it's a bad option
because you don't have four thousand
dollars and I'm not going to tell you to
borrow the money so I went through this
exact same thing I was 28 years old and
going through bankruptcy and they came
out and the guy threatened to turn off
to turn it over to the gas company and
turn it off because it was dangerous
which I found out later was a complete
lie and was a technique to get me to buy
a furnace from him I threw him out of my
house and ended up getting the thing
fixed for 350 bucks from another guy it
wasn't fixed well it didn't last five
years for that but it made it through
the winter and I was too broke to do
otherwise I later had to buy it first I
need to do yeah I later had to buy a
furnace but what I want you to do is the
patch cheap to get through one year
until you can get some money saved up
and then we'll talk about what we do
with an 80 year old furnace and an 80
year old or 31 year old furniture house
right okay but yeah I I
I'm not I'm not saying this guy's a
crook I'm saying that there really is
guys in the business that their deal is
to just come over and go whoop you gotta
have a new one and it's really their
their repairs are a lost leader for sale
for sales of a furnace is what they're
after gotcha and I'm not saying this
guy's that guy and I'm not saying all
big big retail uh with with 27 trucks do
that there's a lot of those guys are
great guys I endorse them in a whole
bunch of cities and so uh but what
you're looking for is the broke 23 year
old help me please because I'm dying
here get through the winter
okay and I got a thousand bucks for
calling me down yeah and I got a
thousand bucks and so you got a little
time before you're gonna freeze to death
here so
but you're in Des Moines so it's going
to happen faster than it does to us in
Tennessee but you know you haven't got
three months to fix this but you do have
a couple weeks and you can take your
time and shop around and uh well Dave
let's say hypothetically speaking
somebody's listening and their AC
actually went out like can't be repaired
and AC is different sorry
technical AC I'll tell you about a fan
shut up you get those for 12.95 at
Walmart right but all right so their
heat goes out yeah and they have a
thousand dollar emergency fund baby step
two what would you tell them
I'm gonna find a way to heat the house
for the money that I have okay don't
replace it just I am not going to spend
three thousand dollars I'm not going
into debt I quit borrowing money and the
thing is this here's what's interesting
when you draw a line in the sand and you
say that's it's like like we talk about
with you with student loans with the
student with the students when you take
debt off the table
it's you find other ways to do it right
maybe there's something you can sell
maybe there's an extra job you can pick
up I mean you may not have two really
good things I didn't even bring up have
a huge garage sale this weekend right
and sell everything in sight
um you know sell all the stuff you know
I mean what's more important to you than
heat not much right you know food and
heat those are two biggies and so um you
know what have I got that I can get rid
of well I got this old car that's an
extra car I was kind of going to work me
up it's gone gotta have heat yeah and it
may be the next four weekends you know
you're just working towards nine hours a
day non-stop or the next you know three
weeks you're working 90 hours a week
just ubering your little butt off you
know and uh you you can find some money
you're right I should have brought both
those things up that's really good input
uh I got I got sidetracked with the heat
and air business there for a minute but
um but yeah that's yeah extra work extra
work extra work garage sales sell stuff
uh Craigslist whatever I mean anything
you can do to get rid of to get you some
money uh because Murphy can still hit in
baby step two yeah it's like you just
gotta get really strategic and be
willing to hustle yeah I mean we we did
all kinds of stuff when we were broke
Sharon and I and we had no money at all
none and you know you just had to figure
out a way to survive and piece something
together and barely fix something until
we had the money I mean we put uh this
uh tar stuff on the roof where it was
leaking and it looked like white trash I
mean but instead of like shingles up
there it was all smeared but it quit
leaking and I didn't have six thousand
dollars to put a roof on the house a
year later I put a roof on the house for
six thousand dollars but I didn't have
six thousand dollars right then and it's
dripping through the fixture onto the
kitchen table we had to do something so
and we're not borrowing money we were
through borrowing money because until
you're through borrowing money everyone
in America solves all their problems by
running out and borrowing money and you
just have to take it off the table and
say this is not an option once you break
that bone you will never go back well
you'll never go back it's amazing when
debt is completely off the table then
you find these Creative Solutions when
that is not an option you will be
willing to do things like a patch job
you'll be willing to work 90 hours for
the next few weeks because
Community College for the first two
years because it's free and all those
credits transfer to the state school and
you go to in-state tuition and you work
your butt off and you save up and you
pay cash and then you don't graduate
with ninety seven thousand dollars in
student loan debt with a degree in
left-handed puppetry or polka history
you know and then wonder why you can't
get a job and you're up up to your
eyeballs in debt hoping Biden is going
to save your little butt you know and it
just doesn't work that way so you just
got to think different you've got to
have a sense of hustle and grind a sense
of personal dignity and responsibility
and Jack's a cool guy I mean he's 23
years old he's asking this question that
you know what that means I mean he's got
the rest of his life to be smart Jack
this is very cool it's very cool that
he's 23 and asking this question very
very very well done
that puts this hour the Ramsey Show in
the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where that
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice
Christina Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today we're taking your calls if
you are a millionaire this is a baby
steps millionaire theme hour we are
going to be talking only with
millionaires regardless of how you
became one we want to hear your story
now let's be very careful to Define it
because some people don't know the
definition of millionaires including
people who think they do a millionaire
is someone who has a one million dollar
or greater net worth your net worth is
defined it is an accounting term as your
assets minus lot your liabilities what
you own
minus what you owe
equals your net worth
if you're a cash millionaire it means
you have at least a million in cash
okay but if you have a house if you have
retirement if you have whatever the
things that you own added up minus what
you owe if it equals one million dollars
or more you are a millionaire and we
want to talk to you because we want to
teach America what millionaires really
look like not what idiots on news shows
with political agendas think of million
areas I heard some Congressman a U.S
congressman the other day goes well he's
not a millionaire he doesn't make a
million dollars a year that's not what a
millionaire is you doofus it's not an
income measure it's net worth how do you
get into the U.S Congress and be this
stupid oh there's a lot of ways okay or
Tick Tock lots of tick tock millionaires
about Tick-Tock millionaires I don't
even know what a millionaire is Tick
Tock doesn't know what anything is so
anyway check it out if you're a real
millionaire we want to talk to real
people not your broke brother-in-law's
opinion I don't want to hear about your
politics or what you wish things were or
you're whining I want to talk to real
millionaires and learn how you really
did it so that our audience knows what
it looks like what it feels like and
what the process is the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jason and Shannon are starting our
million babies millionaire theme hour
off well hey guys what's your net worth
hey we're hey Dave glad to be on the
show uh we're at 3.5 good for you well
done nice job okay give me a little
breakdown on that by category how much
in each category
yeah so our home is about 1.4
got a business worth about 1.6
roughly 150 in our 401k
about 400 in cash
very good well done how old are you guys
44. okay 45. very good what kind of
business have you got
uh sandwich shop oh very good good for
you fun so how much of your 3.5 million
did you inherit
zero none zero okay well you did this
really early what's been your best year
of working income and your worst year of
working income
um
early on was probably pretty rough we'd
be household income under 50. I would
guess out of college yep and uh last
year close to 400. very good good for
you guys well done okay so your career
is your small business owner sandwich
shop right correct yeah okay and what's
your do you have degrees
uh carpentry degree degree for myself
after me sales and marketing okay all
right and what were your uh you got a
carpentry degree so like an
apprenticeship or a technical school or
what yeah essentially technical school
took a couple years of generals and just
finished with the technical college
um built the business there doing some
remodeling and then made the jump into
um a franchisee and small business owner
um as far as that goes so built a couple
different locations and sold a couple
and and now
glad to be debt-free also yeah very good
so what was your GPA back when you were
in school
[Music]
mine was that I had the same one you had
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
so uh 3.0 or less
yes sir okay all right I'm going with
that
I love it okay so uh
I got a 24 year old version of you
listening right now and I do out of 22
million people out there I'm sure I've
got a 24 year old version of you
listening talk to that person a can this
still be done in America today
yeah I would say to the 24 year old 100
um it can be done the biggest piece is
just hard work and continuing to get up
each day and go out and do it I know you
mentioned killing something dragging at
home I mean that that's just what has to
be done especially those early days
looking back on what it took to get
businesses going and even have an asset
to be able to sell
um there was a lot of work a lot of
grinding I had multiple people come up
and say we were going to do this we
thought of doing this you know as
customers and it just
you got to kind of get off the fence and
do it so it it took a lot took a lot but
very thankful and humbled where we're at
now that's amazing and getting to 3.5
million that is no accident there's I'm
sure you have a lot that's happened in
your journey what would you say is the
biggest challenge you had along the way
um
we're actually scheduled to come and
share do our debt free stream in
December so maybe I'll go a little more
in depth then but the biggest challenge
was actually getting on the side with
SBA and just going around with another
business partner and digging a hole a
little too deep and then realizing what
does it take to get out of the
partnership and to get on Solid Ground
and to eliminate debt essentially yeah
get rid of Partners get rid of debt yeah
yeah sir and then that gives you some
peace of mind here at 44 years old with
the whole stinking thing paid for
yeah that's right beautiful beautiful
well done
go ahead did y'all set out to be
millionaires or or did you follow like
it with intention did you plan did you
fight for it tell us a little bit about
that Journey
um you know a lot of the the net worth
piece too comes into that carpentry
background I was able to get my hands
dirty build some homes for us but
ultimately we have four children oldest
is 20 now so I mean he's really close to
the 24 year old that we'd be talking to
um my wife wanted to stay home with kids
and to not have her at work took took a
bigger step for me to move family and to
get into something different and to
really have to stretch as to um
what to do next
um and then there was some growth
opportunity and we continue to pursue
that you know I'm convinced today with
all the whining that's going on out
there
um and the carrying on that uh you know
quiet quitting and uh my goal is
mediocrity and I sure want the
government to have Universal income so I
don't have to work and I can just sit
and play game boy all day long or
whatever it is Call of Duty or whatever
and
um I'm convinced with all of that that
someone that's just willing to work as
hard as you have worked as an inordinate
advantage in America today
oh completely agree completely agree I
still employed still running business
still employ a lot of that demographic
of the 16 to 25 year olds and I I deal
with it every day yeah there's some
studs in that age group but there's some
Duds in that age group too yeah just
like there is in every age group by the
way there's some Duds in my age group
too
most of them are still smoking pot at 65
years old this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
is my co-host we're talking to real
millionaires asking them how they did it
hoping that you might take a cue and
knowing that you can do it
uh let me tell you no one accidentally
becomes wealthy no one accidentally
becomes healthy
no one accidentally takes care of their
marriage
and grazing great children is never an
accident
successful living is always an act of
intentionality
and a level of intensity and a level of
work that other people won't do
that's why we recognize successful
people and we say wow
there's a bar set there wow this is
worth doing wow I want a marriage that
looks like that wow I want kids that
turn out like that wow and you then you
should immediately if you're smart you
ask how'd you do that
and that's what we're doing this hour
it's a baby steps millionaire theme hour
it's not an accident to win America if
you want to be somebody you got to light
your butt on fire you got to get with it
winning is Not an Accident nor is it
anything to be ashamed of
and any of your friends who happen to be
left-wing socialist remind them of that
winning is still a good thing because it
always involves people getting lifted
people getting helped people getting
better so light your butt on fire and go
be somebody that's what this hour is
about Adam and Ashley are with us in
Oklahoma City what's you guys net worth
hey Dave our net worth is just over a
million dollars so you just did it
awesomeness give me a little breakdown
on that
what's the categories yeah so our uh our
retirement between retirement accounts
and savings accounts we have about seven
hundred thousand uh we've got a rental
property that's paid off and worth about
a hundred and thirty thousand
um our primary residence is also paid
for that's worth about a hundred and
eighty thousand okay and then we've got
a couple of vehicles that are paid for
that uh combined are worth about fifty
five thousand cool and how old are you
guys
I'm 35 and my wife Ashley here is 33.
okay very cool young millionaires so
you're just getting there very good how
much of this did you inherit
zero the way to go cool and your best
year of working income and your worst
year of working income since you became
adults
um our worst year uh well we started
this journey about a decade ago and
um we were making about 80 000 at that
time
and then last year would have been our
best year uh we we made just over 200
000. cool what do you all do for a
living
I work in insurance and I'm a teacher
awesomeness yeah teacher the number
three most likely category of career to
become a millionaire pretty cool all
right and so your degrees I assume yours
was in teaching
correct uh actually special education
and special ed okay and uh what about
yours Adam
I have a business degree of course okay
and what were your gpas
um mine was probably about three two
three three I'm gonna say maybe three
five yep okay very cool very cool now
let's see did I get my wires crossed or
did you guys do a debt free scream
uh we did so uh I mentioned that we kind
of started this journey frankly
unknowingly but uh about a decade ago
um so we got married in 2012. uh in
September of 2012 and
um 23 and 25 years old
uh-huh yep
and uh and we we were fortunate enough
to not have any debt coming into the
marriage and so we bought a house
together and
um we looked at each other and we just
said hey we can
I think we can get this thing paid off
um and obviously we knew about you at
the time and about three months into our
marriage we actually went through FPU uh
which that just kind of lit the fire uh
and that's when we went you know gazelle
intents and within 24 months is when we
paid off our uh our primary residence at
that time uh and so we did the debt free
stream I think it was technically 2015
it was about three months after we paid
the house office when we came up and did
the debt free stream wow so you've done
the whole thing Financial Peace
University debt free scream and now baby
steps Millionaire's theme hour you've
done the whole deal buddy
yeah it's it's pretty cool and and we're
actually currently right now uh teaching
FPU oh thank you we're we're giving back
yeah well thank you I love that y'all
are truly baby steps millionaires you
have done the plan from the very
beginning and have just crushed it I'm
curious now since you all started so
young right after you got married early
20s is there anything you would have
done different what would you tell your
25 year old self
it's hard to say that when when we're
sitting here having this conversation
frankly uh from a financial perspective
I know y'all pretty much have nailed it
yeah I mean obviously there were some
sacrifices along the way
um it's not easy like you said it's a
it's a baby step process
um it's been like I said 10 years in the
making so uh it's it's some days are
longer than others but at the same time
you know you wake up and here we are you
know we have a million dollar net worth
and uh
I think it's just taking it one day at a
time staying focused how does that feel
does it is it like do you own it
emotionally or does it feel a little bit
surreal like it's happening to someone
else
surreal honestly um we didn't even
realize that we had hit this um
accomplishment we I walked into the
bedroom one night my husband of course
is doing numbers I'm like what are you
doing he's like I'm trying to figure out
what we're worth and I'm like why and
he's like I don't know I haven't done it
a while and he looked up at me and he
goes babe we're worth a million
hey Bureau you're a millionaire
exactly
I was like I like it away I like it I
like it that's fun I think are walking
proof for any young people listening who
are who are picking up Financial Peace
University who are looking at Baby Steps
millionaires it's going wow man
millionaires are 40 year olds they're 50
year olds no you can see this 33 and
this 35 year old who started in their
early 20s and here they are they are
millionaires they just followed the plan
and did it married 10 years and seven
years ago did the debt free scream house
and everything and so you 25 year olds
out there listening this is you if
you'll just bother and do it and quit
believing the lies that are floating
around the culture out there that that
the little Moon because you guys
inherited zero no one did this for you
no one gave you this this is not a
government grant this is you did it so
fabulous we're so proud of you guys very
very very well done
there's a lot of myths right now running
around gen Z and my generation that you
know we can't be millionaires because
you know it's the cards are stacked
against us it's just it's different now
and I just I love hearing this story I
love seeing young people win on the show
because we can't believe that lie it can
still happen for this generation today
you know those lies that mythology the
biggest danger of it is it steals
people's hope
and hope Steelers are people I want to
kick their butt you know so people that
perpetuate those kinds of lies are ones
that need their butts kicked and because
it's a lie and some people don't
knowingly that they're not like I'm
trying to screw up people's lives but
you are so you need to shut your
negative mouth because you don't know
what the flip you're talking about so
this is one of the reasons I wrote Baby
Steps millionaires was in response and
so I come at it from a spiritual
perspective a math perspective an
investment perspective
um stories of real people that did it
and that's why the book is another my
eighth number one bestseller but um it
all came out of starting to do this hour
because I kept hearing those same exact
myths those hope Steelers are putting
out there that well there's systemic
problems with the economy with wealth
inequality and
you just really you really don't want to
get your theology from Tick Tock it's a
bad idea you don't want to get your life
game from that you so you need to
actually talk to real people that are
winning out there there and go wait a
minute the math says that Adam and
Ashley did this in 10 years and it
didn't just come from an inheritance it
didn't come because they make six
hundred thousand dollars a year it's
somebody who works in insurance and it's
a teacher yep and they just had the
discipline to stick with a plan and do
it consistently over 10 years and the
other guy was a carpenter who bought a
sandwich shop and then another one and
then sold one of them to get rid of a
partner you know made mistakes but still
I mean there's no magic here boys and
girls it's just doing it and that's why
we do this theme hour to give you hope
and also to rub the Lefty's nose in the
fact that America is not so broken you
can't win anymore this is a Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christina Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions this hour is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour we started this
hour because as Christina was saying in
the last segment gen Z but also every
generation for that matter has believed
lies about millionaires that they
inherited their wealth
that
all rich people are evil in their Crooks
the way to become wealthies rip people
off
some people believe that I remember
hearing that growing up a lot
that most rich people the the most
likely way to become rich is you have to
be famous you have to be like a an NBA
star a Major League Baseball star an NFL
star a country music star Beyonce you
know Kanye you got to be that or you or
God help you the Kardashians right in
order to be a millionaire you know
Rachel on her podcast the other day blew
me away I Kim K's net worth is 1.8
billion with a B
that's one that that's a hundred and
eighty thousand million
blows my mind yeah pretty wild so it's
worked out for but the uh as far as the
financial part anyway the um
oh man anyway I got sidetracked but yeah
the uh so you don't have to but do you
have to be famous to be millionaires and
the other thing that people believe is
and this one's a little lesser of a myth
but that the only people that become
millionaires are the super geniuses
you know the 4.2 like you gpas right
that was your GPA right no what was your
GPA 3.8 3.9 I thought you were like a
3.85 yeah because you're you're you're
one of the smarter people in the
building I mean you're intellect so I
figure I'm a little surprised it's that
low honestly oh do you think so yeah hey
part of my message is that you don't
have to be a perfect student twin
scholarships I know I know but you but
you no wait a minute you're grad work
you jack I did it oh God yes all right
when you got to grad school you got you
leaned into it once I got to college I
figured it out okay that's what I'm
talking about but anyway the average
millionaire does not have a a GPA above
3.5
okay very seldom very few of them have a
1.5 turns out you do need some gray
matter to pull this off uh and you need
to do something when you're in college
other than beer pong but um but yeah
there's that but but this idea that you
have to be brilliant or you have to
steal from people or you have to be
famous or you have to inherit it is the
only way to get money those are all lies
statistically
they're lies factual studies including
the Ramsey research on millionaires the
largest study of millionaire has ever
done indicates that all four of those
things are absolute lies and when people
believe lies and they act on lies
meaning well I couldn't be a millionaire
I'd inherited I don't know Rich Uncle
shut up Dave Ramsey
Crypt Dave Ramsey you can't do that you
know I'm gonna get rich on my airline
miles
I'm gonna run up my credit cards and get
airline miles you know I'm P people when
you believe stupid stuff you do stupid
stuff when you believe lies you live a
life that's full of disasters well
there's so many lies now out there it's
like there's so many people trying to
get rich quick there's so many people
with Tick Tock stories and Bitcoin
stories and all these different things
that it's tempting to fall into that
trap yeah but the number of by the way
as you study Millionaires and even Deco
millionaires people with 10 million
dollars the number of them that are
famous is less than one tenth of one
percent of the rich people wow in other
words
99.9
of the rich people you never heard of
them
there you go I mean that's that's
they're not so you don't have to go do
something stupid
to get on a reality show to be rich you
could just work yeah good old-fashioned
work be a teacher be an engineer be an
accountant that's the top three
categories of people who became
millionaires in our study by the way
Stephanie is in Green Bay Stephanie
what's your net worth
just over 1 million good for you well
done give me a little breakdown on that
um our home is worth 750 000 we do have
a little bit of a mortgage on that yet
um 450 000 in retirement accounts thirty
thousand in college savings and 50 000
in savings and other cash great job how
old are you
34. good how much of this did you
inherit
zero all right and best year working
income as an adult worse your working
income as an adult
uh we started out making about a hundred
thousand and now we're north of 300. wow
what do you do for a living
uh I'm an actuary and my husband is a
physical therapist okay so I assume his
degree is at PT right
correct and uh yours business or Finance
or
business okay what was your GPA
we were both at 3.3 okay there you go I
just made my case again all right cool
all right way to go and you're only 34
years old you're baby millionaires
excellent you're gonna be so rich by the
time you're old oh my gosh
so what's the plan so what um
what but how did you do this what do you
attribute this to
uh we encountered your teachings about
seven years ago and just followed the
plan pretty boring so your baby steps
millionaires then
yep following the baby steps house is
not even quite paid off
yep so you're still in four five and six
yep how much you owe on the house
250. okay yeah you got a little ways to
go then good okay well y'all done very
well done I love that you started seven
years ago that again goes back to that
case that a 20 year old starting
somebody in their 20s just doing the
plans seven years look at you now
baby steps millionaire what advice do
you have for a 24 year old 10 years
younger than you
uh take it slow and steady I know you
guys were talking about the tick tocks
and the Bitcoins the get Rick get rich
quick and it just doesn't work that way
the slow and steady
um scrutinize the needs versus your
wants
um and if you are married being locked
up with your spouse that's all the that
that's what you need yeah big time
so uh are you guys boring or do you have
a life uh
we think we have a life yep we have
three kids so they keep us pretty busy
okay all right yeah that's that's a life
right there in and of itself but I mean
you don't you don't never go out to eat
you don't live in a cave and collect
lent you're not like weird
no no no we're pretty normal yeah go on
vacation with their family go out to eat
once in a while nothing extravagant but
but both have worked your careers and
you both have degrees with 3.3 GPA and
you just leaned in uh for a decade or
seven years ago you started with
Financial Peace University and here you
are well done I'm very proud of you good
work
it's incredible it's incredible
excellent excellent Heroes well done
Gary is in Denver hey Gary what's your
net worth
3.3 million Dave cool give me a little
breakdown on that
300 000 in Savings in brokerage 1.1 in
retirement accounts in 1.9 in four
different real estate properties Equity
awesome okay not all paid off then
none of them are paid off unfortunately
no no okay all right that's why you said
Equity I was picking up on that all
right how old are you yep yep I'm 54 and
my wife's 49. excellent how much of this
did you inherit
zero okay and your best year working uh
lifetime as an adult best your income
and worse your income as an adult
best household year was 750 believe it
or not and our worst was 46 000. okay
cool what do y'all do for a living
we're both in Sales Management we're
both sales leaders okay well you did
well then excellent that 750 is a nice
year when was that
about four years ago yeah one one year
everything just popped that one year
yeah before the pandemic yeah okay and
you got four-year degrees
well that's what I both do mine's in
accounting and my wife is in marketing
okay and your your gpas
I'm going to make your case um if you
round up my GPA with a 2.8 okay
and my wife's was a 3.1 ah you married
up good for you
I love it well done what do you
attribute having this Fabulous net worth
to having inherited no money
at 54 years old
there's a lot of things did you know the
budget listen to you guys just being
diligent intentional but you know Dave
the one thing for me and I don't know
how to put a finger on it but there was
some point in time it came from my wife
well I just realized I like having money
more than I like having stuff you know
it just you know it's just there's more
fun that way I don't know you wanted to
invest rather than consume and that's
where that's a really good line right
there well done sir well done it's a
baby steps millionaires theme hour with
Christina Ellis this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot of ways to become a
millionaire
you can follow a lot of plans you don't
have to have followed our plan to get
there nor do you have to have followed
our plan to be on the show and tell your
baby steps story we did have one guy
call in one time who had inherited a
million dollars last year his parents
died left him a million dollars that's
how he got it okay it's unusual
statistically and but we want to put him
on we have one guy call in or one gal
call in that uh hit the lottery
and uh but again statistically very
unusual uh it's not a method that you
can use to become wealthy but it did
happen and so we put it on so uh today
we've had a lot of people say they went
through Financial Peace University did
one did their debt free scream here
seven years ago so if you want to know
about this uh and you want to get out of
that so that you can build wealth so
that you can change your family tree so
that you can be outrageously generous to
your community
Financial Peace University will show you
how to do that we've helped over 10
million families learn how to handle
money properly
and it's the most prolific
personal finance class in America today
more people have been through it than
any other finance class out there and
it's the most successful by far that's
why more people have been through it
it's a proven plan if you've not been
through Financial Peace University just
go to ramsaysolutions.com FPU and get
signed up it's very easy to do it's nine
lessons and we're going to walk you
right through it and we'll show you
exactly what to do and it's it just
works we're going to shoot some stuff
about money that you always wondered you
didn't know about insurance you got
screwed you didn't know about real
estate and you got the wrong kind of
loan you didn't know about getting out
of debt you thought you could borrow
your way out so you got a debt con
consolidation loan you got conned and we
get screwed because we don't know or we
don't take action because we don't know
we don't believe and this will give you
a proven plan and you'll feel the
progress and you'll get yourself out of
debt and put yourself in a position to
be generous to your family and to others
which is really what money is all about
at the end of the day so it's a
millionaire theme hour baby steps
millionaires we're talking to Marilyn
next she's in Atlanta Hi Marilyn what's
your net worth
2.7 million very cool and give me a
little breakdown by category
uh we have as my husband and myself we
have 1.3 in our 401ks 487 in an IRA 200
in cash and uh 785 and paid off real
estate awesome well done how old are you
54. 54 5-4
yes that's correct okay making sure I
heard you correctly and you and how much
others did you inherit
uh absolutely nothing zero okay your
best year of working income as adults
they're worse here
our first year was probably when we
started out in the late 80s at around 25
000 combined and then our best years are
right now and we average from 250 to
290. okay cool what do y'all do for a
living
we are both in health care I started out
as RNs and kind of worked our way up
through into management so okay start as
nurses and then you're in in management
and Health Care from that
degrees in nursing I assume
yes
in business I have one in business with
okay gpas
um
mine was a little bit better than his
around 3.5 because it's probably around
us two to eight to a three so two two uh
around a two eight okay very good very
cool all right well nursing is a a
wonderful uh
career especially today because there's
a shortage like never before uh post
covered post jab uh the number of people
that left the business is unbelievable
as you know I'm sure right right so
there's a shortage of teachers of
policemen and nurses right now in
America like never before and so uh it's
a it's a fabulous career field to get in
you can kind of name your deal right now
can't you yes you sure can you sure can
I tell you it's very unusual I don't
know how many times I've run into
somebody that used nursing to go all the
way into management though that's
unusual what made you guys decide to do
that
it was uh moving from a hospital
environment taking a chance and going to
an industrial environment and then just
going into management through into
corporations I see okay so okay wow
interesting very interesting so with
nursing you can do anything so it's um
it's it's very it's a great career yeah
I have to tell you when I was 34 I was
driving through Jackson Mississippi and
we were like everyone else you know car
payments credit card payments house
payments all those things and young
children and I was listening to the
radio and I heard some mad man screaming
on the radio about me and my money
management is So I listened all the way
from there back to Atlanta and I got
hooked uh and so took it home to my
husband we got hooked at age 34 and
we've taught FPU in our church and then
in our work and so it's just been a
great thing and I just want to thank you
for you taking your you know your pains
and your problems your mistakes and
using those to invest in other people to
help them so well thank you yeah that's
20 years ago I was still the madman then
it's not gotten any better it's not
gotten any better it's just gotten
crazier so that's fine you're awesome
thank you so much for sharing your story
We Appreciate You Marilyn what would you
tell what would you tell that 34 year
old version of you that was that was
going down the highway struggling credit
card debt all of that and now you're a
millionaire what would you tell that
girl uh I would tell them to start
saving earlier live off lesson they make
and we've always been faithful to give
and save since we've discovered day
we've give and we save until it hurts
and that's just kind of part of what we
do now look like no one else good word
give and save until it hurts can't mess
up with those two you really can't mess
that up that's a pretty good formula
right there all right so we've got a
sandwich shop owner a teacher an
insurance broker an Actuarial a physical
therapist couple of sales managers and a
couple of RNs that went into management
3.5 net worth 1 million net worth 1
million net worth 3.3 and two point 7
million net worth 44 33 34 54 54. no 87
year olds
and no 22 year olds
notice the trend
okay it takes a little time
the tortoise wins the race not the hair
get rich quick doesn't work but this
idea that you can't become wealthy early
enough in life to have a good life and
enjoy your life is ridiculous maybe we
I'm YOLO you only live once
Thank God It's Friday oh God it's Monday
now you're a child
children do what feels good adults
devise a plan and follow it we've been
talking to adults this hour
grown-ups
people with spiritual and emotional
maturity and the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater good the changing
of their family trees and these are the
people that become millionaires
Christina yep and a lot of them are
young adults I think a lot of people
think though 24 and 33 were two of them
right exactly a lot of 25 year olds
aren't willing to join onto this journey
because they think it's going to take 30
years but it's like these people are
walking proof it took them seven years
in one case ten years in another and
it's like they were just willing to be
consistent follow a plan and be patient
but they don't have to be patient for 30
40 years in our study it was 12 to 17
years from the time you lean in start
working the baby steps and do the stuff
seriously
12 to 17 years to go from zero to a
million dollar net worth and that is
worth it that's what we found it wasn't
34 years now some people took 34 I'm
talking about averages I mean you can
you can drag it out but with normal
incomes and normal raises and um just
not doing normal stuff there's no new
cars in the plan
there's no car leasing in the plan
there's no uh trips around the world
when you make thirty six thousand
dollars a year and I'm gonna I'm gonna
quite quit I'm not going to work very
hard those people aren't in there
they're not in there they're not in this
they don't show up because they don't
make it don't make it they get run over
by life right but on the flip side of
that you talk to that one of the callers
and she said they weren't weird about it
though they weren't on ramen noodles for
the entire journey to becoming a
millionaire no they already get out of
debt the first time and then start
working their baby steps properly from
there that's what they do and so you
don't you know the average millionaire
is not a crook so when somebody says
that call them a liar
the average millionaire is not an
Entertainer and a famous person tell
them they're a liar
89 percent of millionaires inherited
precisely not enough to become
millionaires they're not millionaires
because of inherited money we had not
talked to a single person today that
inherited a dime not one
so the next time some Lefty says that
just tell them they're wrong
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
really love and create real amazing
relationships Christina Ellis Ramsey
personality is number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five folks if you like this show
would you help us out by doing three
things one subscribe to it on YouTube or
podcast if you're doing that push the
memory button on your radio if you're a
radio listener make sure you've always
got us tuned in second thing is if
you're in a situation like YouTube or
podcast leave a review of five star
preferably we don't really need anyone
Stars they're not helpful and also share
it with a friend tell people but listen
tell people to tune in and tell them how
to do it send you know if you've got a
YouTube or a podcast generally they have
a share function and you can just push
the share button and send a link to them
and say Hey listen to this I did that
with my friend Mike Rose podcast this
week I was listening to it or last week
rather I was listening to it and sent uh
Ken Coleman because it's all about jobs
and stuff as you might guess with Mr
Dirty Jobs himself right so um yeah good
stuff hey thanks for joining us America
we're glad you're here triple eight
eight two five five two two five Bruce
is with us and Bruce is in Abilene Texas
hi Bruce welcome to the Ramsay show
they just want to say we love loving all
of you you guys are great thank you
Bruce how can we help
well I started a business in the first
couple years I used a credit card uh all
I mean a debit card all the time and I
was having to break down anywhere from
180 to 220 transactions on my bank
statement every month and it was an
accounting nightmare now here's where I
get in trouble I got five credit cards
for my LLC one's for Sealcoat one's for
aggregate one's for fuel one's for
asphalt one's for supplies there's
always money in the bank and they're all
on autopay and it has taken all the
accounting nightmare away and I'm
is it possibly is it possible to be an
exception to the little
uh I don't understand why five debit
cards wouldn't do exactly the same thing
well because I've gotten a you know free
iPhone I get travel points you know you
didn't tell me about free crap you said
accounting nightmare
it is and you went to five credit cards
why would five debit cards not do the
exact same thing for your accounting
on a debit card could I have five
different ones on one account
yeah they'd have different they'd have
different numbers on them I've got 78 on
one account
Ramsey Solutions runs on debit cards
that goes to show me okay well I I hear
you and I'll make the transition yeah
and here's the thing you can do whatever
you want to do Bruce obviously you're
not going broke from this if you're Auto
paying them and you're not carrying any
balances but what I what I've had to
learn to do was two things and and I I
became fanatical about it and I think
the fanaticism helped me and I and
that's why I'm going to continue selling
it
um
okay uh the the fanatical thing number
one I did was I figured out smart things
that I could automate
and I put Auto I put smart on auto
meaning like Auto uh deduct from my
paycheck going into a 401k Auto deduct
from my checking account in the early
days when they very first started doing
it I was one of the first ones to do it
to pay my utilities always on time and I
always got the discount
okay Auto saving into
kids college coming out of my checking
account Auto saving going into the Roth
IRA out of my checking account every
month so I did smart things on auto that
was the first thing I did I automated
smart and the second thing I did was
anything that looked like a snake it
could bite me I don't play with it
and a credit card that is a snake for
sure
that can bite you even though you've got
your pretty good Snake Charmer you got
them kind of tamed you got them laying
in a you know five distinct buckets and
you've got them on auto pay and all that
kind of stuff you've at least smart did
the auto pay that was a smart move you
know but you still you know you play
with snakes long enough you're gonna get
bit and that's the problem and and so
that's why I just don't have a credit
card and I haven't all these years I
don't want to accidentally end up in
debt
it's just not going to happen I know I
don't owe anyone any money under any
circumstances because I don't have any
tools that I use in the financial world
that can result in debt it's impossible
because I don't sign up
and so I I I stay away from things that
I can accidentally get bit with number
one number two I get Auto I put smart on
auto and those two things take even
because I kept I'm smart enough I kept
trying to outsmart all this crap and
scheming and scamming you know and it'll
get you I think that's a lot of people's
stories I mean most people who start out
using credit cards they don't think
they're going to be the person thirty
thousand dollars in debt no one does no
one no one takes it out it and I got 10
off at
Macy's and I got the discount no one
ever says and I'm going to end up on
these bozos three grand for 400 years no
one says that no one they just got I got
10 off I got a friend IPhone you know
Bruce I'll make fun of you right okay
whatever right and so that's no one says
oh god look I'm gonna go let's go I'm
intentionally gonna go the average
credit card right now is 22 percent
ouch with inflation the banks helped you
out they went up okay because they
inflated the interest rate from 18 the
average is 22 so no one says I'm going
to intentionally go deeply in debt at 22
percent and then wonder why I'm broke no
one says that you're right everyone sees
the points they see the bonuses and they
think that they're going to be the ones
that take advantage of the system they
beat the system and yet the system is
still building skyscrapers they're still
taking people thousands of dollars in
debt yeah
now I do know people that have credit
cards that pay them off every month and
they're not going to cause them to go
bankrupt but you are walking around with
a very small rattlesnake in your pocket
and the small ones bite harder than the
big ones I hear you know so be careful
sneaky just be careful yeah you don't
see them coming they don't they don't
hold back they love they empty all their
venom and so yeah it's it's a problem
and so I just I don't you know I'm gonna
put a home equity line of credit on my
home but we're not going to draw on it
but it'll just be there in case
I need a bass boat in case I want to go
to Disney World in case and yeah you're
in case changes later and then but you
set yourself up you're playing with
snakes and you put a financial thing in
place that allows you to do that and um
another one of these is overdraft
protection
we're going to set up overdraft
protection you're never going to be in
overdraft because it turns into a loan
and guess what
a hundred percent of the time that's
going to turn into a loan
this is what happens with it well and
I'm being wise I don't want to pay any
overdraft fees well here's an idea don't
run your dad gum checking account down
to zero and actually keep up with what's
money's in there
why is this hard
it's not hard but we rationalize our
butts off out there I do I do it too
Bruce has done it I've done it
Christina's done it we've all done it
the question is what's the shortest
fastest best path most proven path to
wealth and it's not that this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Christine Alice number one best-selling
author Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones here on the Ramsey
Show we're glad you're with us it's
launch week for our brand new gazelle
debit card
this is the coolest looking debit card
ever and it is the debit card that will
help you spend and save the Ramsey Way
we don't use credit cards here the
gazelle debit card works the same as
your standard debit card with the same
FDIC protections no fees
some of these cards have more fees than
a French poodle Fifi Fifi Fifi
and you know you just don't want to get
it signed up with that stuff so got
built-in accountability for your budget
it ties you directly into every dollar
the app and so if you're doing your
budgeting app if you want to spend and
save the Ramsay way this is a brand new
thing we just launched this week we're
very excited about it no we're not in
the banking business there's a bank that
stands behind this product and is
actually where your money is going
that's where the FDIC insurance comes
from the fraud protection comes from
MasterCard the same as with any good
MasterCard debit card or Visa debit card
for that matter and so go to
ramseysolutions.com gazelle to get
started today it's free to create an
account and Christina uh the guys in the
booth James and such Austin suggested
that we remind people that
um
we teach in Financial Peace University
and we were just talking about it at the
last in the last segment uh you don't
carry a credit card I don't carry a
credit card Ramsey the Ramsay way is we
don't have credit cards period
period okay so part of following
this Proven Plan
is to not have a credit card
here's what's really
um
interesting and sad
50 percent of the applications that come
in to do a debt free Scream one of the
things we ask is are you still using a
credit card
50 are saying yes
100 of those that say yes do not get to
do their desk free scream and a portion
of those are pissed off
because they're not following our plans
so they're not doing a debt free scream
here because we're not going to promote
you're stupid
we want to promote smart here that's
what the debt free scream is about it's
about a milestone a goal that you
achieved and that you are following the
Ramsey system and you're out of debt and
you're staying out of debt you're not
going to use a credit card and so if you
are using a credit card don't even apply
to do your debt free scream
because the answer will be no we're not
gonna let you do it and so you can get
mad if you want to get mad uh go get
your own show then you can do your own
debt free screen you know uh this one
says Ramsey on it and Ramsey don't do
credit cards so
um just helping the guys out in the
booth because they get all the Flack
from you people that are mad at them
when I went and did all these travel to
get out of debt now you won't let me do
my debt free screaming that's because
you're still stupid
that's why and so just just let you know
where you stand on that and we're not
doing it we're not doing it I don't
think I'm stupid that's good that's fine
you go do your own just go stand your
driveway and scream I'm debt free but
you're not coming on here and do it well
in the heart behind it is we want you to
stay debt free forever hello right it's
it's for your own good so that you know
you eliminate that Temptation so that
you're not walking around with that
rattlesnake in your pocket exactly all
right our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay and you'll get the best deal
today's question comes from Tommy in
California in 2009 my mom took out a
parent plus loan for me to go to college
I also took out seventy thousand dollars
of student loans she never made a
payment towards them in her mind it was
it was my loan under her name that I
should pick up whatever I'm financially
stable because my mom never paid she now
owes a hundred thousand dollars and is
begging me to take it back under my name
I just got a new job where I make a
hundred and forty three thousand dollars
it's a huge jump from the Thirty to
forty thousand I've made for several
years and I can finally make a dent in
my own loans she asks me every week or
so when are you taking your student
loans back ouch
my mom is a nurse practitioner
practitioner but often complains that
she is broke she is currently paying off
two luxury cars that she bought within
24 hours of each other one for work one
for church
okay who has a church car a luxury
church I had a church car
so great
loans that she borrowed from her 401k to
purchase land and other credit cards she
says that her own student loans are such
a burden that she had to stop paying her
life insurance to afford the payments
should I take the hundred thousand
dollars back under my name since she
feels like she was tricked into getting
them
there is a lot your mom is a freaking
Head Case oh my God
man that that's there's a lot of sticky
stuff you're a child and I'm an adult
and I take that alone in my name for you
to go to college but I got tricked
and I'm still being irresponsible with
my money
so has this woman ever done anything
wrong in her own eyes she has a church
car for God's sakes I'm going home and
telling Sharon I need another car I
don't have a church car I need another
car I knew that I knew I needed a car I
just didn't know what it was for it's
for church
geez what in the world that's weird oh
man and so much guilt and shame in that
yeah so here's the thing if you promised
your mom when you were a child
that if she took out these Parent Plus
Loans that you would pay them and you
and you pinky swears but shake at the
kitchen table when you're 18 years old
and you told her you would cover them
then you should cover them but the story
I just read or the Christina just read
doesn't say that
it sounds like your mom did this she was
trying to help she did a stupid thing
trying to do a good thing and she's done
a lot of stupid things in her life you
listed a whole bunch of them here and um
and and now she wants to dump it on you
so here's what I would do
um
number one under no circumstances do you
take it back under your name okay
uh number two if you choose to help her
with it you can help her by throwing
grenades over the fence throwing money
over the fence but we're not going to
move the loan over into your name okay
uh besides that I'm not even positive
you can pull that off with a parent plus
loan I think it's pretty well stuck in
her name and you're not qualified so
first thing you're going to do is you're
going to get your stuff paid off so no
you can't help her until you're debt
free
then if you choose to help her at that
point
here's how the conversation would be if
it was me you can do whatever you want
to do but it would be mom
you are really ridiculously done with
money
I am willing to help you with you taking
out this loan because it was for my
benefit
um but I'm not willing to do it all and
I'm not willing to do it while you're
paying two car payments including a
church car
just shoot me I mean that's just stupid
straight up stupid and a nurse
practitioner should be making a pile of
money in California you should be able
to work your way through a lot of this
stuff so we're gonna get rid of a bunch
of cars I'm going to help you do that
I'm going to be your biggest cheerleader
you're going to get on a budget you're
going to go through Financial Peace
University and then every thousand
dollars you pay on that old Parent PLUS
Loan I'll put a thousand dollars on it
oh I like that if you pay nothing on it
and you continue to stay out of control
I'm gonna match that
nothing
that's exactly I'm gonna put on exactly
what you put on and I'm going to help
you get this out of control under
control get your life back coach you
through a complete transformation
because darling you need one
but you know this idea that somehow she
is a victim she's a victim of her own
stupidity like all of us are when I went
bankrupt you know whose fault it was
Dave's
it wasn't Ronald Reagan's
he was the president
it wasn't Jimmy Carter's he was the
President right before that and both of
them did some really stupid stuff but
neither one of them calls me to go
bankrupt it was Dave's fault
and it wasn't my dad's fault and it
wasn't my mom's fault and it wasn't my
dog's fault it was my fault so part of
part of straightening up your dad gum
life is taking responsibility for it
yeah and I think this just also
highlights what I think I've heard
Rachel say where it's like a lot of the
student loan crisis is a parenting
crisis it's parents letting their kids
go into debt but if you're a parent who
takes out a Parent PLUS Loan and then
expects your kid to pay it off that's
that's a lot that's rough well I mean
some parents do that and the kid says
okay I'll promise then you made the
promise I'll stick you to your promise
then but he didn't do that but even even
if your kid says I promise that 18 years
old that is still a kid I barely an
adult promising to pay that back like as
a parent you should stop and say are you
really willing to make that promise do
you understand what that promise means
in the long run because that's a heavy
promise to make it 18 years old like one
of you parents co-signing for a 16 year
old to get a BMW you're an idiot
you're an idiot you deserve the problems
that are coming your way you just signed
up for stupid on steroids this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions I'm the debt free stage Braden
and Nadia are with us hey guys how are
you hi everybody
good to have you where do you guys live
uh we're from Scottsburg Indiana but we
neighbor Louisville Kentucky ah gotcha
okay welcome to Nashville ah how much
data have you paid off
uh 138 thousand dollars all right how
long did this take four years and eight
months okay and your range of income
during that almost five years uh started
at forty thousand and then we worked it
up to 160 000. yeah we're about 160.
nice jump well done what do you all do
for a living
uh work at my family's used car
dealership and I'm a hair stylist very
good very good so what do you attribute
this huge income increase over five
years to I got pay raises over the next
few years and then Nadia she began
working yeah I when we met I had just
finished hair school and but pretty much
the last year I've doubled my income oh
wow so really just focusing on my career
and talking about that both of you are
in the zone yeah well done what kind of
debt was 138 000. I love about ten
thousand eleven thousand were my student
loans and then the rest was the mortgage
oh you paid off your house yes look at
the weird people
pause so what how what's this house
worth
uh the current market probably somewhere
around 240 000 I love it how old are you
two I'm 30. I'm 26.
I'd have paid four hours 250 000 quarter
of a million dollar paid for a house
whoa
oh whoa all right tell us what happens
you're man you started this young yeah
y'all were baby children when you
started this like 20 years old you
started right yeah we met when I I just
turned 21. okay so what in the world
what made you plug into this whole
Ramsay thing at that age uh to be honest
before I met her I went to college and
just went just to go and then I ended up
dropping out after a year and then I
kind of set up a goal after that that I
was gonna
um buy a house and save up for a down
payment uh from talking with my mom and
then I bought your book and I read it at
the time and it just kind of set a fire
underneath me to start saving up for the
next four years and just putting all my
money towards a big down payment for a
house wow okay and then kind of fast
forward
um we met
right after I graduated school I had my
student loans I didn't have a job yet
and then he had already been searching
for a house for a while so he a few
months after we met he bought the house
and we both moved in and you know for
the first couple of years the income was
about 40 000 and then I started working
but uh it was really just you know we
always had the long-term goal of paying
it off early he I don't think realized
that we could do it as quickly so we
were on a walk during covid and um kind
of locked down and I was like we can do
this and you know maybe I think we said
four or five years but then that was
kind of I can control my income so it
was that driving force for me that I
wanted to accelerate and just serve my
clients and and the people and around me
and use that as kind of the driving
force to increase my income wow that's
amazing I love that and I love that
you're so young I love that you even saw
your job as service you're like I can
serve my clients better and in that use
that money to Propel us forward exactly
so what would you tell people is the key
the key to getting out of debt the key I
think just being intentional with your
money and then if you're with someone
being transparent and putting making
sure you have one goal and going for it
which is amazing especially as such a
young couple you guys are building such
a strong foundation not only financially
but with your conversations and in your
marriage yeah early on so when we moved
into the house I found the book just on
a shelf or something and I immediately
read it because it clicked it made all
made sense to me immediately so I was
like so I used you know the Snowball
Effect to pay off my student loans and
um and then so early on we had those
those financial discussions and the
money money discussions but I would say
that just staying content through this
whole time was a huge
um a huge thing because as our money our
income increased we easily could have
Justified to spend and you know spend a
ton of money on our wedding um so we got
married a year ago and then combining
our finances was the key like it cannot
achieve any goal together if if you're
not doing it financially together in the
same bank account and and always always
talking about it so because we did that
combined our income the last year we
paid off eighty thousand whoa I love
that so so the blind share this in one
year yeah wow yeah so we spent our first
year of marriage
um I would say we sacrificed a lot of
time
um together and we didn't take vacations
but it was because we could see the
Finish Line yeah it's right there I can
I can touch it I can smell it I'm doing
this yeah I love it I love it how does
it feel to be completely free it's great
it was amazing yeah I feel like it's
just now starting to hit us it's been a
few months um but it's it's kind of wild
just to think we're planning a trip next
year where are you going and uh we're
going to Hawaii yeah good trip very good
y'all have earned that very good who
were your biggest cheerleaders
uh my mom she's really she's a big saver
and kind of goes with your principles
and things so she kind of lit a fire
under me to do this and then when I read
your book it was more explain your book
explained why I was doing these things
that she was kind of telling me to do
beforehand yeah and I would say my
parents as well my mom I remember years
ago my mom paid off her house and I just
thought like oh wow that's you know
that's wild
um and uh and then just so to me it was
always a tangible thing but you have to
believe it if you don't believe you can
achieve these goals then it's never
going to happen what do you think made
you guys open to believing it because I
think a lot of people a lot of parents
even hate to have these conversations
with their kids because they think that
you know they're not interested they're
not going to believe it but what was
different about y'all
I I feel like I've grown up and always
believed that you know you set your mind
to something and you just you can do it
and so setting small goals and once you
can see yourself achieving those goals
um and then you can learn to apply those
to some larger goals but really learning
to just kind of break it down because I
remember we we passed the 100 000 mark
on the house and it was just like oh wow
and then we would celebrate kind of
every you know five thousand and ten
thousand and then but that's the
motivating motivating force is is being
able to to visualize all that and track
it is is really important I think Kevin
faith in what you do in the beginning
that it's going to pay off later on and
then as you get closer to time then
you're just gonna allow the fire
underneath you to finish it like kind of
like the last year we were so close we
just kept pouring more and more money
towards it but at first you just kind of
got to believe that it's gonna work
later on well and it makes you really
question the things that you purchase
and spend your money your money on and
it really makes you like I'm like I'm
good driving my five thousand dollar car
like I I I'm now hesitant to think he's
got a whole lot of cars over there
exactly exactly so I don't even know I'm
like you don't have a church car we
don't know
um but but yeah you just have to uh you
really start to reevaluate your entire
life and what's important
especially in your 20s because you've
got friends that are probably having
lavish weddings and driving fancy cars
and just sitting in their student loan
debt not worried at all about paying it
off but not well my wedding dress costs
less than a hundred dollars and I think
I diy'd and got things second hand from
for our entire house like all the
furniture everything it was like I I was
building things myself and we were going
to Goodwill we shopped at Goodwill for
our clothes and furniture and everything
for years wow wow and now you can do
anything you want to do we can do
anything yes yeah I mean this is pretty
cool you make a couple hundred thousand
a year real soon and not a payment in
the world you're gonna be baby steps
millionaires in a heartbeat here that's
the plan well done very very well done
live like no one else now you can live
and give like no one else absolutely
it's a beautiful thing yes proud of you
guys well done thank you very well done
you're an impressive young couple very
very well done good stuff hey we got a
copy of The Total Money Makeover book
for you you can give that away like Mom
gave it to you and get somebody started
baby steps millionaires book our latest
number one best seller and that'll of
course be the next chapter in your story
a one-year membership to Financial Peace
University if you haven't been through
it go through it if you have then give
it away and all of this is the live and
give bundle it'll help you with all of
both of those things very well done
Braden and Nadia Louisville Kentucky
area 138 000 paid off in four years and
eight months house and everything
making 40 all the way to 160. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're dead free
[Applause]
gotta love it man you gotta love it man
they're impressive is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day Romans 8 38 39
for I am convinced that neither death
nor life neither angels nor demons
neither the present nor the future nor
any powers neither height nor depth nor
anything else in all creation will be
able to separate us from the love of God
that is in Christ Jesus our lord
Corey ten boom says God takes our sins
the past present and future and dumps
them in the sea and puts up a sign that
says no fishing allowed I
you gotta love that so Christina there
is quite a little stir going on uh even
among the uh Ramsay baby steppers
Community uh about these eye bonds uh
we've got a couple of days if you want
to put money into an i Bond and get 9.62
annual interest for series I bonds and
so because the rate has gotten so high
uh it's gotten everybody's attention not
everybody's attention but people are
buzzing about it
um and so people are saying Dave what
should we do what should we do what
should we do well
um let me tell you that what how much
money I have in I bonds and how much
money I will be putting in I bonds
precisely zero
hmm
why is that well 9.62 is the annualized
interest rate for the first six months
after six months it will drop to
whatever the prevailing rate is at that
time and that has traditionally been
down closer to five percent uh we're
thinking most people are thinking it's
gonna be about six and a half percent
beginning in November so you're pretty
sure it's going to drop at least to that
after six months and if you do not leave
your I Bond alone five years to cash it
out early
you get charged three months of the
interest that would be one-fourth of the
interest and so if you average six and a
half and nine and a half uh you would
get eight and three quarter something
like that or eight and a half roughly
um and
seven seven and some change anyway and
then take a fourth of that away
uh that's what you're gonna be making
and even less because it's going to
adjust down further later so the problem
is this it's giving you it's giving you
decent it's giving you way above average
short-term interest rates but it's not
really a short-term interest product
it punishes you if you don't leave it
alone long term and it's a lousy
long-term product because I can make a
lot more than 962 on average investing
in good mutual funds stock market is
averaged north of 11 percent I've been
investing in mutual funds for 40 years
and I've averaged Way north of 12
percent on my mutual funds over that
number of years way better than 9.6 oh
wait it's not really 9.6 it's only 9.6
for six months oh wait you can't get it
out earlier than five years unless you
get one fourth of the three months of
interest is a penalty and so people
don't read the small all they do is read
the big and the big print says 9.6 9.6
you get can't beat 9.6 9.6 is amazing
it's amazing and yeah it is amazing
that's a great interest rate I'm sure if
I could get 9.6 on a six-month CD
I would take it absolutely and I you
know I talk about moving some of my
emergency fund there maybe but that's
not the terms on this
the terms are five years or you have a
three-month penalty
the terms are it's not 9.6 for a year
it's 9.6 for six months on a one-year
Bond and you know what the last six
months are no you don't because they
don't tell you until later
it could be anything and I bonds have
traditionally hovered down in the five
and sub five range throughout their
history this is an anomaly that's jumped
up and so well I think you just can't
lock it in and so it's a myth right and
it's getting a bunch of hype in the news
and the headlines are saying that 9.6
percent and then at the very bottom of
the article it says in like a small
paragraph the downsides and it explains
that change in the lock and all of that
so it's important to not just get lost
in the height but we'll realize the CNBC
article we have laying in front of us
for instance is your last chance to
secure 9.62 annual interest rate for
series I bonds is October 28th wait a
minute
not true
it's not annual
it's calculated as annual but only for
six months six months is not annual so I
mean right off the bat we've misled with
the headline but uh and so but it gives
you something to write about it's click
bait it causes people to jump on your
little site and read your little stuff
so uh it you're not stupid if you do
this but you're stupid if you do this
thinking you're going to get 9.6 percent
for more than six months
minus three months if you cash it out
early so if you're using this for
emergency fund you cash it out early
you're going to negate most of what's
there so I don't screw around with this
stuff it's a variable interest rate
product with long-term implications and
heavy fees for cashing out early so it's
not a good short-term product and it
doesn't make enough to be a long-term
product so I don't have any money in it
that's why I don't have any money I'm
not trashing it it's just you guys you
just got to read to learn to look at
these things a little more carefully and
once you realize all the the gotchas
then you go well it's just not as sexy
as it sounds yeah not not quite as
attractive as the headlines make it seem
absolutely all right Morgan is with us
in Baltimore hey Morgan welcome to the
Ramsey Show get straight to it before we
run out of time okay how much time do we
have not much go all right I'm gonna go
um so many questions but the major one
is okay I have three kids they are 10
almost nine and six I'm wondering how
much you really need to put away per kid
for college I know there's not an easy
answer
well the closer you are to college the
more you're going to do almost all of it
in actual Cash There's not going to be a
lot of growth so you only got about
eight years for this money to grow
I'm putting away
I was born so you've already started
okay oh we have listen we have like a
lot of cash reserves hundreds of
thousands we have money on the market we
have money in all these different
buckets so thank God we had a lot of
disposable income but I want to know
um how much of it really realistically
you might need to put away for their
college because maybe the average
in-state tuition today is about twelve
thousand dollars
right average in-state
plus room and board and so if you say 20
grand times 4 is 80 grand
and if that's if they're going to go to
an in-state school and you're going to
put them in a dorm okay and so
um you know you got 80 grand a kid now
how much have you got and how much is it
going to grow in eight years
to cover that and that's that's the
calculation and so it would be different
for a three-year-old than it would a 13
year old
yeah I'm not going to solely rely on the
529 but you think the number is 80 grand
per kid if it's in state I'll call it
100 call it 100. yeah because we're not
there yet and it's going to go up
I'm gonna go out yeah and if you're
feeling stressed and anxious about or
you just want to be as accurate as
possible and as close to the number as
possible I would definitely sit down
with a smart investor Pro I mean that's
what we do and they can really help you
lay out exactly how much you should be
putting out putting aside every month
for each kid at their various age and
you can you can use how much you've got
now how old the kid is and what mutual
funds you're invested in and what
they've been returning and use that
formula and it will tell you exactly
what you need to put in there once you
establish a Target amount with a
smartvester pro but my point is you can
do some quick numbers and go hey my
target is a minimum of 100 a kid
uh and that's if they do bare minimum
schools okay and they get out in four
years hello uh there's a there's a
little miracle for you
um and so you know all of that and so
we've got to start training the kids and
um and but yeah Christine is exactly
right I would sit down with a Smart
Vista Pro and you can get the exact
numbers and I would put the right amount
in a 529 to end up equaling about a
hundred at 18 years old yes get it there
it can also just reduce some of that
stress and anxiety because College costs
are going up and you know you got kids
at different ages so just to have
someone walk through the math with you
and just give you that assurance that
you're on the right track it can just
give you a lot of Peace in that area
yeah it sounds like you've got the money
it's just scattered all over hell's hand
basket so if you just pull it all
together and line it up and get it you
know make it dance with a Smart Vista
Pro and put it and make these ducks get
in a row with a 529 in a good mutual
fund you're at least going to get seven
or eight years of tax-free growth on
each of these kids and using the 529 and
good mutual funds that's going to be a
good plan so that's what I would do go
to ramseysolutions.com click smart
investor Pro and you'll find somebody
there with the heart of a teacher and
help you sort through the actual numbers
but it sounds like you probably are on
track but you just need to get them
lined up
Christina good job Austin Ben Zach
Andrew and James in the booth good job
I'm Dave Ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign